He might not be the X-Men’s most famous
foe, but the Juggernaut has been around for
over 50 years, with a complicated history
that ties him to everyone from Spider-Man
to Professor X to Doctor Strange.
If you want to know his story, here’s the
truth behind Cain Marko, the unstoppable Juggernaut.
The Uncanny X-Brothers
Before the Juggernaut even appears on panel
in Uncanny X-Men #12, Professor Xavier fills
the X-Men in on his origin story.
As a youngster, the smart and sensitive Charles
was bullied by his older stepbrother, Cain
Marko.
They were rivals their whole lives, although
Xavier was able to get the upper hand when
his psychic powers manifested.
When the pair happened across "the sacred,
lost Temple of Cyttorak,", however, Cain grabbed
a ruby from a strange-looking statue, and
it transformed him into the unstoppable behemoth
known as the Juggernaut.
The cave collapsed and buried Marko, but it
turns out that “unstoppable” wasn’t
just a catchphrase.
Years later, Marko returned to hunt down his
step-brother with a distinctive helmet which
made him immune to Professor X's psychic powers.
That first battle with the X-Men, like many
that followed, was all about getting that
helmet off, enabling Xavier to lay down the
psychic whammy.
“I’m trying to attack his mind… but
I can't get through.
His helmet protects his mind from probes”
The power of Cyttorak
It wasn’t mentioned in the early stories,
but in 1992’s Doctor Strange: Sorcerer Supreme
#44, Cyttorak was revealed to be a demon who
had been banished to another dimension.
He's a being of destruction and chaos, which
is why he chooses Earthly avatars like Cain
Marko and grants them the power to cause untold
devastation in his name.
In a 2015 storyline, Cyttorak's appearance
was redefined, mirroring the Juggernaut’s
traditional red armor and domed helmet by
making him a big red creature with a large
domed head.
By giving shape to the character and motivations
of Cyttorak and showing the Juggernaut as
his earthly avatar, Cain Marko’s actions
were given a whole new meaning.
They were chaotic, to be sure, but they were
exactly as chaotic as Cyttorak wanted them
to be.
Black Tom’s BFF
In Uncanny X-Men #101, Chris Claremont and
Dave Cockrum introduced one of the weirdest
partnerships in comics when the Juggernaut
teamed up with Black Tom Cassidy, the cousin
of the X-Man known as Banshee.
In the first story, their alliance really
only existed to justify the Juggernaut's surprising
presence in Cassidy Keep, but the pair remained
allies for years, and it’s safe to say that
Black Tom got the better end of that deal.
The Juggernaut is, after all, a legendarily
unstoppable supervillain who can level mountains
and bring down buildings with a single punch.
Black Tom Cassidy, on the other hand, is more
of a schemer, and at one point suffered from
a disease that was turning him into a tree.
Not exactly the most threatening mutant, but
when your real power is being best friends
with the Juggernaut, you don’t really need
to be.
Juggernaut versus everybody
While he tends to square off against the X-Men,
the Juggernaut’s path of destruction isn’t
just limited to the mutant corner of the Marvel
Universe.
After all, a huge guy who smashes through
walls and can't be stopped by any known force
is a useful sort of all-purpose villain to
have around.
He met Doctor Strange for the first of several
battles in 1969, since getting his powers
from a demonic artifact made him a natural
villain for the sorcerer supreme.
While the X-Men were taking a break in the
early 1970s, the Juggernaut fought the newly
blue Beast in Amazing Adventures #16, and
took on Marvel's other famous unstoppable
behemoth in The Incredible Hulk #172.
He would throw down with Thor several times,
including a story that also introduced a team
of young heroes known as the New Warriors,
and even fought his share of bad guys during
a brief stint as a member of the X-Men.
And of course, he’s slugged it out with
Deadpool on plenty of occasions.
The Juggernaut's greatest battle, however,
might also have been the single best story
he ever appeared in: "Nothing Can Stop the
Juggernaut."
In that story, Juggernaut arrives in New York
City in an attempt to kidnap the psychic Madame
Web.
Spider-Man tries to stop him, but finds out
that the title of the story is pretty accurate.
Fortunately, stopping the unstoppable is what
Spider-Man does.
For all of his spidery abilities, one of Peter
Parker’s most important traits is his unwillingness
to give up, no matter how hopeless things
might seem.
Rather than trying to match the Juggernaut
physically, Spider-Man eventually outsmarts
his unstoppable foe by tricking him into burying
himself in 40 feet of wet cement.
The greatest bar fight ever
The Juggernaut has met the X-Men on plenty
of different battlefields, but the most memorable
might be a dive bar in Manhattan.
It happened in Uncanny X-Men #183, and was
set in the aftermath of the original Secret
Wars.
Among other things, that crossover saw Colossus
falling in love with an alien who promptly
died, leading him to break up with his long-time
love interest Kitty Pryde once he returned
to Earth.
Unfortunately for Colossus, Wolverine has
always been protective of Kitty, and decides
to take his Russian teammate out to a bar,
get him drunk, and then beat him up.
He's spared the trouble, however, by the coincidental
appearance of an out-of-costume Cain Marko.
Wolverine manipulates the two into fighting,
and then he and Nightcrawler stand back and
watch as the two super-strong giants have
one of the greatest barroom brawls of all
time.
The entire establishment is destroyed in the
fight, although the Juggernaut surprises everyone
by donating a massive roll of cash to fund
its reconstruction.
He takes off, Colossus learns his lesson,
and Wolverine is satisfied with the night
out.
X-Men: The Last Stand
The Juggernaut made his cinematic debut in
2006's X-Men: The Last Stand.
With a very charitable 58 percent rating on
Rotten Tomatoes, that movie is commonly regarded
as a bit of a mess, partly because it introduces
a ton of characters from the comics without
taking the time to actually make them characters.
The Juggernaut, played by Vinnie Jones, definitely
suffers from this problem, although there's
one pretty memorable scene.
"Don't you know who I am?
I'm the Juggernaut, bitch!"
When Juggernaut is chasing Kitty Pryde through
a large building, Kitty uses her mutant powers
to pass through the walls, but the Juggernaut
simply smashes through them like the battering
ram that he is.
And as cool as that action is, the Juggernaut
dropping a reference to a viral video featuring
a fan-dubbed episode of the X-Men cartoon
is even cooler.
Deadpool 2
The Juggernaut's surprise appearance in Deadpool
2 wasn't advertised, but at this point the
word is out.
Unlike The Last Stand, Deadpool 2’s Juggernaut
is an entirely digital creation, and gets
to have a massively over-the-top fight with
his old comics rival, Colossus.
In the credits, Juggernaut is listed as playing
himself, but screenwriter Rhett Reese revealed
to Comic Book Resources that Juggernaut's
voice and facial capture are actually performed
by the same actor as Deadpool: Ryan Reynolds.
Colossus, Negasonic Teenage Warhead, and Yukio
manage to knock the Juggernaut out at the
end of the film, but his return for future
sequels seems inevitable.
After all, nothing can stop the Juggernaut.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!